(drum beats)
- [Female Speaker] Country music
is the worst genre of music.
What do you think?
Answer in the comments below
and suggest a prompt on our Kickstarter.
- We took off in the park,
he kept up a conversation.
Then it start getting dark
I gave him an invitation to my
apartment complex
and it's kind of complex my
brother in the next room.
I don't want to alarm him.
Unh, I'mma sneak you in.
(group exclaims)
- [Male Speaker] If you
had to rank yourself
against others based on a specific trait,
what would it say about
how you see them and how they see you?
We brought together five
rappers to rank each other
based on who they think
is the most talented.
Then our followers rearranged them
based on who they think
is the most talented.
This is Ranking.
- Yo, what up guys, it's your boy,
Digital Dav, I'm a South
Korean artist residing in LA.
Make sure to follow me on Digital Dav X.
Oh, one more time.
Make sure to follow me on digitalxdav.
(laughter and overlapping voices)
(beep)
- What's good, I'm Figgy Baby.
Don't forget the Baby.
LA based artist, internationally tourin'.
- My name's Jason Chu,
Asian-American artist out here,
LA, let's get it.
- What's good y'all? AlphaPatron,
African-American artist
hip hop fusion, I like to
incorporate different things
and I'm just excited to see y'all.
- And I'm Diani from Brooklyn.
- There you go.
- And I'm also excited.
- It's performance, it's preparedness.
It's craft.
- Yeah, craft, mhm.
- It's lyricism, it's
story telling, it's range.
I mean, eye contact,
your ability to connect.
It's a lot of things.
- Music evolves.
And I think nowadays it's
more about having fun.
I appreciate all types of music.
- Yeah.
- Check.
You had me kicked outta the whole city
and you never spoke on my behalf,
or showed pity.
The eight of us students
were the only victims
in the school district acting like
they were ripped out of
eighth grade at 14 with me.
You made me feel like a criminal,
I was a kid.
I was a kid. (beep) y'all.
That's why I never felt
guilty for what I did.
I take back every fake apology.
My father couldn't speak to me for weeks
you made him believe I lost a heart in me,
a drug lord, a banger.
By the juvenile
lived in the room right
across from his, now.
That's both sons.
Mom and dad,
you should really be thanking
Paul for smoking me out.
'Cause I be hitting up gang members
to get me high before he did.
Took the blame to keep me
safe while we breathing.
Stole my first eighth,
so I didn't get deep in.
Didn't yell at me after I ratted him out.
Never was hurt as everyone else.
He knew that I was just a child,
keeping me safe as much as he knew how.
I love you, bro-bro.
- Woo.
(group claps)
- Man, that was beautiful.
I just love the intention.
I love what you're talkin' about.
- And I like that you're talking
on certain things without being preachy.
But just sharing from, from your heart.
So I (beep) with it, man.
- Hey, one, two, three.
'Cause I be dripping like a Hooper.
Hey, I be feeling so cool.
Hey, energy stay super.
Huh? What do I have to lose?
Hey, I be rollin' like andale.
Huh? I gotta finish my food.
Hey, seven seven, like I'm Luka.
Huh? I wanna fly ya to the moon.
Hey, look.
I be ridin', I be vibin'.
Give me the seat, I'mma climb in.
I got that Jah on me,
I'm flyin'.
Flyin'.
Hey, 'cause I drippin' like a Hooper.
Hey, I be feeling so cool.
Hey, energy stay super.
Huh. What do I have to lose?
Hey, I be rollin' like andale.
Hey, I gotta finish my food.
Seven seven, like I'm Luka.
Hey, I wanna fly ya to the moon.
Hey, sing it with me, like,
Like andale, hey, sing it with me,
like andale, hey.
Sing it with me, like andale.
Hey, hey, hey.
- That was fun, man.
That was fun.
- We was all dancin'.
- Like andale.
- We was background dancers.
- Yo them long legs though, really just,
was gettin' all.
- Asian Americans, man.
They call us a model minority.
But what are we the model for?
Why are we a minority in this country?
How we treated, model.
In our wallets, they
thinking we got commas
really in back pockets
we carryin' deep traumas,
hang tied, it's by our own trials.
It's seen as outsiders,
used to red line us.
Time called us not white
and the white scholars
drove a divide between us
and the black brothers.
You got admitted to
dominant white college.
Still you ain't valid for
most of those white collars.
Southeast Asian dark cousins
drive down the streets,
police radio buzzin'.
Gaslighted to thinkin' we made progress.
Still, they killed Christian
Hall, said nothing. Shh.
Not a model, not a monolith.
Yeah. I'm not a poem for your politics.
Yeah, I learned from Gandhi and Dr. King,
if the system don't bring
peace, we must abolish it. Hey.
- All right, all right.
- All right. Cool, cool, cool.
- You know, you're standing
up for us, for minorities.
We need to do that more.
- You know, when people
talk about politics,
you're like, man, I feel
sad after this (beep),
but I'm like, okay. Yeah. There's hope.
- And I loved how you had
those vocals at the chorus.
It really illustrated that well.
- Yeah.
I was lost and I needed some directions.
Hard times, I don't learn my lesson.
Now the lights on me.
Camera, action.
All the lights on me, so fluorescent.
Diamonds when I talk, see it glisten.
Steady making noise, never listen.
Steady payin' dues, countin' blessins.
Yep. Blowing on some
dope, never stressin'.
Got the lights on me.
Camera, action.
All the lights on me, so fluorescent.
Digital Dav. Let's get it.
- Let's get get get it.
- Your intention was
vibe out and have fun.
It served its purpose, bro.
- I do think that, like,
I'm imagining your vocals on the record.
And I feel like if you could find a way
that could even bring more
of that recorded sound
into the live performance.
- True.
- Got the lights on me.
Camera, action.
All the lights on me, so fluorescent.
- I told this boy, I think he's sexy,
figured he liked my energy
before he even met me.
Pretty eyes, I can only
see through pixels and,
I can't even front 'cause
really, I will show these nipples and,
I don't like to waste time.
I just like a great time,
even sit on a FaceTime.
So I think it's FaceTime,
face them one-on-one
with a drink in between.
Same eyes and he's sweet
but I know it's a dream.
We took off in the park.
He kept up a conversation.
Then it start getting dark.
I gave him an invitation
to my apartment complex
and it's kind of complex my
brother in the next room.
I don't want to alarm him.
Unh, I'mma sneak you in.
I'mma sneak you in.
I'mma sneak you in, I'mma sneak you in.
(group exclaims)
- She let him know she gonna
sneak him in. She let him know!
The attitude is what sells you.
- Like I'm not gonna front.
Like I love hearing that
for a women perspective,
it's too, because I
think it's so normalized
for men to be like talking
about their hookup stories
and this and that.
And like to be like, yeah,
yeah, I'm sexual too.
- No, that song is called Sneaky Link.
- Sneaky.
(group exclaims)
- I think we should start
off with who did the best.
Who do you guys think?
- No. Who you think?
- I'm gonna go with Jason.
Because I feel like the
performance was there
in terms of like lyricism, diction,
and all that type o' shit.
- I think that Jason also is top two.
The only thing I'll say is
I think that I'm number one.
And the reason I say
that is because of range,
you know, be able to
have sounds that exist
in completely different, you know, spaces.
You know, I think rappers should be able
to swag out shamelessly and also
be able to tell a vulnerable story.
And my only thought for you is that,
I wanted one of those to
be a lot more personal.
But I was like, what's
Jason Chu's story, right?
- I'm kinda the same way.
Like I'll put myself at number one.
'Cause I felt like for me personally like,
the range as well, the flows
melodically, the cadences.
And just having fun and being personal.
Shoot, man. No, this is hard, man.
- We can all be like what
we think the number one was,
but let's, none of us
can talk about ourselves.
Just 'cause otherwise we
are all gonna be number one.
- I don't think I'm number one.
I think you're number one.
- Oh (beep).
- Stop bein' humble.
(beep)
- There you go.
- I'm tryin' to be cute.
- How 'bout we just all
say no hard feelings?
(group exclaims)
- Yeah, it's subjective.
- And now, let's go.
- Yeah. Where I'm at is
myself, Jason, Diani,
and then Alpha and Dav.
And the only reason I put
Dav last, I think it's fun.
But also, you know, like
in this TikTok viral world
like that's the kind of music
that I hear all the time
and for me it just doesn't
feel, you know, unique.
- That's totally cool.
You know, I was gonna
put you as number five.
So, you know, we all good.
(group laughs, voices overlap)
No hard feelings.
- One, two, three, four, five.
Actually, musically.
Dav, I would put you higher up
because I think your music is really fun.
That's honestly the (beep)
I like driving around to
these days, but I think like I said
it don't necessarily translate
to a live performance.
The next thing I would say
y'all to me was very close
because I love the swagger and attitude,
but I do think that the
presence right here,
your energy was a little more subdued,
your energy, and just how you came alive
in front of the camera, edged it for me.
- I'mma go one, two, three, four, five.
- I think Jason's gotten two ones so far.
- Okay, so I'll start here and
then we might be a little...
(voices overlap)
- I've gotten two twos.
- I got two threes.
- So, 22 twos.
This is how this'll go?
I feel like it should go this way.
(group laughs)
- I'll also be really, really real.
I don't care who thinks I'm number one.
I can be number 100, or
number five, I don't care.
- I do this for fun.
- You know what I'm saying?
Are we out here, you know,
is our music hitting people?
Is our music causing any cultural shift
or are we just sitting
in the studio being like
yo look at my multi.
Celebrate everybody coming up.
- There we go.
- And I think, especially right now
you don't gotta be miracle,
lyrical, spiritual.
You could be vibes going up on TikTok.
- Right.
- And people having fun
and joy and love of that.
That's beautiful.
So I just want to put that out there.
- Find your audience.
- [Male Speaker] In spot
number five, we have Dav.
- Nah.
(group chuckles)
- [Male Speaker] In
spot number four, Jason.
In spot number three, we have Figgy Baby.
- All right, hey, just one little move.
- [Male Speaker] In spot
number two, we have Alpha.
- Appreciate y'all.
- [Male Speaker] In spot
number one, we have Diani.
- Hey.
(group claps)
- Hey, I said you'd be up there.
- I'm a bad bitch.
- I'm cool with it.
These first four, did reverse.
- I'm consistent.
- Hey, that's a skill.
- You know, it's about
finding your audience.
- Context is everything
when it comes to preference.
- We all got lanes.
You know what I'm saying?
And maybe some of our lanes
overlaps with Jubilee,
maybe some of our lanes
the Venn diagram is like,
completely detached.
- You know, obviously
there's gonna be people who
don't like what you do, but just embrace
what you have to offer.
Because I feel like that's
what the world needs, you know?
- Let's go crazy.
Love you guys. Peace.
- It's 11:00 AM, most of
my fans still sleeping.
(group exclaims, chuckles)
- My fans in New York is up.
- That's right.
- New York is up right now!
(voices overlap)
It's Sunday in LA, like
we sleepin' sleepin'.
(group laughs)
- Oh, it's Sunday, isn't it?
- It's Sunday.
- Church.
- You know what I mean.
- My fans are not in church.